هجمات صاروخيه توصف بالاكثر تعقيدا تتعرض
لها العاصمه الاوكرانيه هذه الهجمه هي
الهجمه التاسعه من نوعها التي استهدفت
العاصمه الاوكرانيه كما تقول الاداره
العسكريه في العاصمه كييف والتي تقول انها
كانت معقده نظرا لاستخدام القوات الروسيه
صواريخ من طراز 101 اطلقت من قاذفات
استراتيجيه فوق بحر قزوين تقول السلطات
الاوكرانيه انها اعترضت هذه الصواريخ التي
وجهت نحو العاصمه الاوكرانيه وكما تشاهدون
هذا حطام احد الصواريخ الذي سقط في منطقه
مدنيه وسط العاصمه الاوكرانيه بعدما تمكنت
الدفاعات الجويه على ما يبدو من اعتراضه
في سماء العاصمه
وحطام هذه الصواريخ ايضا توجد في عدد من
المناطق في العاصمه الاوكرانيه كييف تقول
السلطات الاوكرانيه ان هذه الهجمات تعتبر
هجمات معقده نظرا لاطلاق مسيرات انتحاريه
بالتزامن مع اطلاق هذا النوع من الصواريخ
بكثافه باتجاه العاصمه الاوكرانيه هي
معركه في الاجواء بين الدفاعات الجويه
والصواريخ التي تطلق باتجاه العاصمه
الاوكرانيه هو عدد من المناطق الاوكرانيه
على امتداد مساحه البلاد حسن مسعود
الجزيره كيف